If a doctor is concerned that
a patient either has diabetes
or is at risk from
diabetes, they
might suggest an A1C
test to be performed.
And what I want to
do in this video is,
one, just explore
what A1C even means,
and also how that
actually relates
to diabetes, or the main side
effect of diabetes, which
is having high blood
sugar or hyperglycemia.
So to do that, let's think
about red blood cells,
and I know what
you're thinking, what
does this have to
do with diabetes?
And we'll get there
in a little bit.
So red blood cells are the main
oxygen carriers in our blood,
they kind of look
like these lozenges,
and inside of red
blood cells you
have hundreds of
millions of hemoglobin
molecules, hemoglobin proteins.
So let me draw some
hemoglobin proteins.
You actually have, the number
I found is 200 to 300 million
per red blood cell,
and then we have
tens of trillions
of red blood cells.
So we have a lot of
hemoglobin in us,
and hemoglobin is what
makes red blood cells red.
When hemoglobin is bound to
oxygen it has a red color.
So this right here, each of
those are a hemoglobin protein.
Now, it turns out
that hemoglobin--
let me draw a bigger
version of it--
if it has some glucose
around-- so let
me draw some glucose floating
around near the hemoglobin--
if it has some glucose
around, there is some chance,
it's not a high
probability, but there's
some chance if the
hemoglobin and the glucose
bump into each other
in just the right way,
that they'll bind to each other.
And so you'll have
this situation
where you have glucose
bound to the hemoglobin.
Now, this hemoglobin with
a glucose bound to it
is called glycated hemoglobin.
I wrote "glycated"
in green because I'm
using green for the glucose.
And another name for
glycated hemoglobin,
or hemoglobin that has
some glucose bound to it,
is hemoglobin A1C.
And now I can imagine
things are starting
to click in your brain.
When you are measuring
your A1C levels,
that's a test of the percentage
of your hemoglobin, that
is hemoglobin A1C.
So you take a
blood test, they're
measuring relative to the total
amount of hemoglobin there,
what percentage of
that is hemoglobin A1C?
And a normal range of
that, so if you just
have normal blood sugar over
a reasonable amount of time,
you are going to
have a hemoglobin A1C
level in kind of
the 4 to 6% range.
And people are still kind
of trying to tighten up
these ranges, and it
doesn't completely
correlate tightly with the
blood sugar, it does correlate,
but people with the
same blood sugar
can still have fairly different
A1C levels, but 4 to 6%
is considered normal.
And if you have higher than 7
or 8%, so greater than 7 to 8%,
so if you had like an A1C
level of 9 or 10%, that's high.
And so you can
imagine, this is kind
of a proxy for how much glucose
you have in your bloodstream.
Because the more glucose you
have in your bloodstream,
the higher the probability
that that glucose
is going to react with
the actual hemoglobin.
So you're going to have a higher
percentage of hemoglobin A1C.
And the other reason
why this is useful,
and it's kind of, I guess you
can see on the first pass, it's
useful because it's not one
of these snapshot tests.
Everything we've talked about
so far with respect to diabetes
is taking your blood sugar
at any one point in time,
and we know that your
blood sugar changes
throughout the day,
it changes depending
on how active you are,
on what you might
have just eaten.
So when you do blood sugar,
you're just getting a sample,
you don't know what the blood
sugar is throughout the day,
unless you just kept sampling
it, which could get pretty
annoying, keep
pricking your needle.
With A1C, this starts to become
a measure of how much glucose
you have in your blood over
a longer period of time.
And, in general,
it's kind of used
as a measure for the last few
months, because the red blood
cells and the
hemoglobin in them,
they have a lifespan
of about 120 days.
Now, that obviously doesn't
mean that all of your hemoglobin
gets produced on one day and
then all dies 120 days later.
You have some red blood
cells and hemoglobin
that might be a few
seconds old, and then you
have some that might be
approaching 120 days old.
So on average they're going
to be about 60 days old
or about 2 months old.
So when you're measuring
this percentage,
you're definitely not getting
the percentage of anything
older than 120 days,
and on average you
are seeing things that are
from about two months old.
So the higher this percentage,
this is saying, wow,
my average hemoglobin
molecule in my body
is only maybe 60 days old at
this point, and already 7 to 8%
of them have already
been glycated,
which is an indicator that
I probably have more blood
sugar than a normal person.
In a normal situation, only
4 to 6% of my hemoglobin
would get glycated.
So hopefully that
explains what A1C is.
But I do want to say, I said
at the beginning of the video,
I'm not a doctor, and even
amongst doctors, the A1C test
or the A1C measurement,
it's a little bit,
there's some debate
about how useful it is,
what it's measuring, or kind
of how far back it actually
is a good view at kind
of your glucose levels.
And also, as I
mentioned, two people
with the exact same blood sugars
could have different A1C levels
depending on other things.
How old they are,
or whether they
have some other type
of medical condition.